venez venez les cherry et tous les
autres ils sont partis en plateau on va
prendre un verre merci à tous ça c'est
ça que vous aimez un bien sûr les idées
que nous sommes très très plaisir d'être
venu et d'enseignants contrées comme ça
c'est vraiment un plaisir est génial
arrête c où les terrasses sait où qui a
des terrains
merci allez on va les voir on va les
embêter plan du jeu vous dire que je
veux vraiment qu'on a vite plein de gens
remonter très bon extérieur toi aussi
[Rires]
quoi sert ce faire ces boîtes avait pas
moins jugé certains entendent j'ai pas
pu devient votre quartier sont les
hommes et les autres qu'il est plus bas
qu est bien plus ça va nous coûter de
l'oseille là me feras tu vois ça rien
sans le goût des données alors c'est ou
à droite
donné on va voir un petit peu ca du
monde en terrassant bien sûr on en
direct sais c'est que du kif
on va les voir quand j'ai regardé ouais
c'est bien il ya une terrasse ah bah
voilà il ya trois personnes qui se
battent en duel
les mecs choix de la joie de moi de
faire une terrasse devant chez picard un
petit à petit car enfin ce désert ils
sont venus au resto mais finances et
bien venez venez on va les mariannes que
cette carrière
mais si elle a une là-bas c'était là bas
qu'il fallait aller mon amour il chérit
bah oui mais non il ya quatre personnes
benhaim médaille alors elle va dire par
le vent d'hier 4 personnes 4 comment ça
va fonctionner alors voilà alors je
voulais le dire comme c'est la
réouverture des terrasses c'est pour
nous et je vous offre
c'est pour moi la presse et sur annoncé
pour moi bien sûr c'est pour moi c'est
pas le bébé c'est pour tout le monde
monsieur c'est pour moi pour cette table
la commande et vous mettez des desserts
mettait des tiramisus mettez des
boissons mettez de ce que vous voulez
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau pour la
reverso dias et bonbons non vraiment ça
me semblait tirer de cette fille de
bonne famille franchement qui fait bien
les cherry à l'eau petit bébé qui est là
et bien je vous fais des gros bisous
vous êtes content
ça vous fait du bien
c'est vrai en tout cas vous êtes
magnifique vous êtes bien bronzé vous
êtes très joli très beau toute la
famille et ben voila et ben ça me fait
plaisir parce qu'on voulait voir des
premières personnes qui ont croisé après
le confinement donc en terrasse et c'est
vous annonce à c'est un jeu pourri il a
pas de doute que ça ait sauté
ne vous arrêtez pas avec sa ballade donc
je vous offre voilà bah prenez ce que
vous voulez c'est pour nous et ça nous
fait plaisir
non mais alors pas de papa ou le service
je ne bois pas d'alcool pendant le
service mais ça me fait extrêmement
plaisir alors déjà je voudrais inviter
cette jeune fille aussi qui va s'asseoir
et jean mi je t'invite avec sophie vous
allez prendre un petit verre tous les
deux cette table là c'est pour nous et
le baby blog comment commence à peine sa
peine j'espère qu'il va nous porter
chance pour ceux dits confinement ses
frais les confirme en tout cas et que ça
va bien se passer mercier qualifié et
par repas de soirée et qui fait bien les
chéris ensuite eh bien je vous admire le
confort les chéris je vous invite
reprenez ce que voulait ce que voulaient
autre chose
vous voulez quoi j'entraîne champagne et
champagne balshaw chapatte chapatte pour
mes amis chant pas d'ici là j'aurai été
quelqu'un qui veut du champagne
champagne madame champagne malades
bonsoir madame comment ça va non c'est
beaucoup c'est jean-charles jean-charles
tombera sylla sont charles voilà qui ont
pu enfin soir une petite bouteille pour
la dame la voulait voir quelque chose
merci à nos balles et ben je vous
embrasse moi vous embrasser jean-charles
voilà partis bon les chéris ici
champagne
ici on a du champagne ici donne à la
norme et non non non mais et c'est
énorme et quelqu'un qui comme toi fin
qui fait que j'ai remis merci voilà à
l'ailé shihri bienveillante me sarraf 0
danse à mon frère frère est ce que tu
fais dans la vie rien dire est qu'il
souhaite offrir à boire pour la
réouverture des terrasses n'importe quoi
je t'offre renard ce que tu veux rien
c'est vrai merci en tout cas j'aime bien
mais battant brest femmes s'embrasser
fort merci voilà merci monsieur
voilà sa femme aime bien lui s'en fout
de moi mais bon c'est sympa à merci
attendez je viens aimé mais tu as voulu
m'attaquer toi avec ta caméra qu'ils
peuvent pour un truc on va voir à temps
sur
europe
c'est un frère tu m'as dit avoir un truc
c'est vrai merci bonne elle a les doigts
là c'est vous la laideur qui l'aident à
s'émousser pour voilà jusqu'à ses restes
ont placé pour moi pas si c'est pour
fois merci qui va pas
voilà qu'à défaut ils sont tous comme ça
ils ont peur que les dijonnais a cédé ce
métis à la météo
champagne et pour messieurs champagne
aussi s'il vous plaît ça me fait plaisir
ils sont très sympathiques en plus merci
voilà alors on va inviter des gens là
les chaînages vous savez ils venaient
manger là
[Musique]
j'ai volé n'a pas droit a pas droit
mettez vous la fais cadeau voilà on va
remplir la terrasse ou balade en pire on
va la remplacer thierry beaudet
champagne pour mes amis de sainte
hedwidge se rappelle que l'abus d'alcool
est dangereux pour la santé
mais bon on l'a fait c'est parti c'est
le jour de l'an
et se rend compte qu'un gars c'est son
cas ça me fait plaisir et profiter je
vous en avais pas plus vous inquiétez
pas je vais partir vous allez pouvoir
être tranquille
merci beaucoup venez venez la famille la
donne dans vos chéris attends attends tu
manges un petit truc m'a dit mon cher un
citoyen parce que tu es là bas niveau ce
que tu penses que tu attaques des kits
avec ton père ramène son père allait se
doit après ce que tu veux m'en ce que tu
fais ce que tu veux c'est pas parce que
tu vas vivre une fois parce que tu veux
voilà voilà
on va remplir toute la terrasse est pour
moi ces quatre années qu'est-ce qu'on
ad'autres chats à jpg pas les mettra sur
sa vallée si vous voulez manger un truc
pour un truc
qu'est ce que vous faites vous là
je vous invite
ah ben voilà les chéris bord alors il
est 15 heures bon il est 19 heures dans
trois minutes j'ai rampé comment ça
n'allait vraiment ça va vous voulez pas
je vous invite à manger un truc les
jurys non mais pour la famille tout ça
me plaisait à petit de même qu'un petit
coquin petite rue sur c'est vrai qu'il y
avait je vous amène au resto eh ben
voilà on est quittes ou fait de gros
bisous à la ferté jamais chérie de brad
thorn et chérie
quand tu veux faire les boîtes mâcher la
formule 1 a battu diaconu est en plus
une boîte de transport avec plaisir mon
chéri fait attention ray qui fait bien
ce soir relève au restaurant tranquille
c'est bien qu'est-ce qui est kg à l'are
lui assis toi flauraud c pour moi ces
canaux assieds-toi apprend ce que tu
veux c'est bon je suis là mais le moins
bien mais le mois bien avec ses enfants
mais l'airé de l'année mettez la famille
maman de l'addition c'est pour moi c'est
pour moi frère je rigole pas allez-y
fetwa pdc très beau ici magnifique
champagne shop-in-shop je vous invite si
vous voulez comment ça va beau gosse et
si vous voulez manger un petit truc
n'hésitez pas non mais c'est bon vous
dites à s'amuser pour moi m'a très bien
d'accord voilà bah voila merci fonelle
et chérie qu'est ce qu'ils veulent vous
avez pas marre de ces trucs mais bon ces
trucs pour mes amis je peins du ruc
avoir été truquées ou plus peut savoir
des sûretés paimpol donnerait quoi peut
servir mes amis ce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'alcool bongo quand tu veux quoi tu
menu malades
allez une limonade ou des malades à tout
cas l'un sur la cub
merci monsieur ries merci c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau voilà
ses membres merci les gars toi tu veux
pas de trois cacahuètes ou mac os capot
de chauffe l'air bien tu reviens du même
âge que la balle allait pas mal
[Applaudissements]
320 petite élise a dit ça va mon frère
venait manger là je vous invite
bah différents
d'avoir quitté nice matin à catane